[Music]
there's some question
that i i see played out in different
ways in the culture
and i want to tackle it from a different
angle so like in the parenting story for
example right
lots of people had written about
helicopter parenting i was interested in
what's happening with all these people
who are coming in to see me and they
have these great childhoods you know
it's the opposite of what people think
of therapy
and they're they're depressed or anxious
or you know
unable to kind of function in the ways
that they hope to um
in the story that you were talking about
with the new york times um
about uh you know like what's happening
in marriages i'm really interested i see
a lot of couples and i was curious about
this that
on the one hand people will say to their
husbands like um you know i want you to
be more sensitive
i want you to tell me how you're really
feeling and then they do
and then in the therapy room the women
will be like oh my god he cried
you know it's like i want you to be
sensitive but not so sensitive that i
feel unsafe well why does that make you
feel unsafe you know what is sort of
this hardwired
gender idea that they have you're asking
for one thing and then when he gives it
to you you're repulsed by it
yeah in your practice uh treating
treating couples
what is the what is a recurring thing
that you
that you see like what are what are
people struggling with in terms of how
to relate to each other and
and have productive relationships
i think partly um for younger couples
they don't have a lot of experience
relating because they grew up in sort of
the age of technology
they didn't date in the same way that
earlier generations dated so they have
less
experience with like what happens when
relationships don't look like the movies
and you know they don't have a lot of
maybe communication skills
they have a lot of unrealistic
expectations of what their partner can
provide for them
or what a partner should provide for
them you know he's got to be like
or she has to be my best friend
my um you know rock my world in bed
every single time
um you know read my mind have you know
be telepathic
um you know not not hurt me in any way
um you know they just don't understand
sort of like what happens in
relationships they don't understand sort
of what we call rupture and repair
that people hurt each other or make
mistakes
all the time the question is how do you
guys deal with that and how do you
repair it
what uh what do you think about um
in treating those people or counseling
those people
like what is a picture of a healthy what
does a healthy relationship look like in
terms of how
two people are interacting productively
i think when they can hear each other um
and understand that
everything that they each of them thinks
is subjective
that um you know like when somebody like
if you see a couple and they'll say
here's what happened and the other
person says here's what happened
both things happened this is the
experience of each person so
they're parallel stories that that
happened and there's some like in the
venn diagram there's some overlap where
they agree on sort of yeah but they had
different
experiences of the same situation um and
so a lot of times people will say
something like well
you don't listen to me and i always say
to that person
if you want someone to listen to you ask
yourself how well do i listen to that
person
uh yeah people don't want to hear that
but it's so helpful and when they do
hear it it really makes them stop cold
in the therapy room because they're not
hearing in a critical way
they're hearing like oh wow i didn't
think about that like i'm
talking so much because i'm trying to
make my point i'm trying to get this
person to hear me by talking a lot
and the way that i can get this person
to hear me is by listening to that
person
and when i was training a supervisor
said to me you have two ears and one
mouth there's a reason for that ratio
yeah well i think i think that it's it's
very difficult to not
project upon that other person this idea
of who you think they are and who they
should be
and mentally we create this framework uh
and a rule book for how that person
should behave
to meet our needs right and this is a
sort of an unspoken social contract
that's going in two directions and it's
inevitable that that contract is going
to get
broken and when we're projecting too
much onto that other person
that's what creates conflict and and
heartbreak and all the rest and
my wife and i have been together for a
very long time and one of the things
that we've worked hard on is to
have our own independent lives that that
you know we're not looking to the other
person to you know quote unquote you
know complete each other like we are
complete you know self-sustaining
organisms in our own right and
you know we we navigate the world
together
but also separately and kind of respect
each other in that
in our in our in our in our discrete um
separate paths yeah that's so important
um and i also think that a lot of
couples um
they they don't understand
that they need to get they need to have
their lives together um before they meet
this person
i don't mean totally together you're
going to evolve and you change in the
course of your marriage right you know
you're you
you you're a different person in your
20s than you are in your 30s 40s 50s 60s
etc um but i think that if you feel like
this
hole or this emptiness and you feel like
this other person is going to feel that
for you
well that's a recipe for disaster but
but that's an epidemic
i mean that is just what so many people
do
yeah i also think that people going back
to you know what
people attributing something like
the reason that somebody's acting away
toward you um
so many people are wrong they're just
flat out wrong like
you you when you did this it was because
you wanted this it's like no that's not
why i said that or did that right and
they really need to hear
how wrong their projections can be for
them to start having different kinds of
conversations so they aren't you know
often people are having basically the
same fight every week so i don't do
couples therapy where
we analyze the fight of the week i think
that gets us nowhere
um i want to know the pattern underlying
it so that you don't keep having these
kinds of fights
i don't need to know the specifics of
every single fight i want to see
what is this pattern what is this
conflict that you repeatedly get into
that creates the different fights that
you're having um why is it that
we tend to seek out partners that
reflect the way that we were parented
so i talk about that yeah when it when
it's you know when it was unhealthy like
yeah you know the example in your book
of the woman who ends up in all these
relationships
you know that that that mirrors her
experience as a young girl
right it's almost like what you said
about parenting that we say we're going
to do the opposite of what our parents
did and that we do sort of the same
thing do the same thing
it's the thing about that is with
charlotte she doesn't realize that she
keeps saying well none of these men you
know i can't seem to find a guy who
wants a relationship but she keeps
picking these guys
who are very much like her parents were
um you know which is sort of like
sometimes they're very present
and sometimes they're not they're always
keeping her guessing
um and we grow up and we say i don't
want that that felt bad i want something
different
but it's almost like we have radar for
the familiar yeah
and if you're not aware of it um you're
going to keep choosing people who
tap into that very familiar feeling of
home it almost feels like home to you
even if home was miserable
right you're like right you're like
you're like oh that feels kind of like
my teddy bear that feels like my teddy
bear i recognize that
and the problem is that if you go
outside of your comfort zone if she were
to pick somebody who was
available to her and present and wanted
a relationship
she would feel like what she would do
with him when she's oh i'm not attracted
to him right now it feels foreign
can't we be attracted to the person
that's good for us because it felt
foreign to her right it's like
because it's scary to go outside of your
comfort zone all of a sudden
you're in this strange land and you
don't know the the customs in this land
you don't speak the language in this
land
it's so much more comfortable to cling
to the familiar of
oh i know what that's like to be on edge
and wonder if he calls i know exactly
what that's like i grew up like that
right what's confusing about that though
is i can understand intellectually like
oh that's
that's uncomfortable and confusing but
why the then there's the the the sexual
attraction component to it
it's like why am i sexually attracted to
the person that's not good for me and i
can't find myself sexually attracted to
the person that you know like
how does how does the sexuality aspect
of it get confounded with the other
confusing part well i think the
attraction is holistic
it's not you know it's not
compartmentalized like that so you say
like i'm really drawn to this person
like
like it doesn't even have to be sexual
in the sense of people pick friends like
that too they'll pick like friends who
are not reliable or friends who are kind
of flaky or friends who are addicted if
their parents were addicted
you know they tend to kind of
recapitulate
whatever they grew up in until they
really really understand it and i don't
mean just
have an awareness of it in the book i
say insight is the booby prize of
therapy
because you can have all the insight in
the world like oh now i understand why i
keep picking those guys
but if you don't make changes out in the
world i.e pick
other guys um the insight is useless so
many times people in couples there
people say like oh now i understand why
you know i get really triggered by that
that when you do that
you know or and why i react that way but
then they don't change anything yeah
well you're wasting your time if you're
not going to change anything so i think
in therapy you have to be both
vulnerable and accountable so you have
to be vulnerable
but you also have to be accountable for
what are you going to do with the work
that we're doing
how are you going to make some tangible
changes in your
behavior when you leave here the change
part is so hard
right and people don't realize that they
think oh it's positive change so it
should be easy because people
want something better to happen but with
every change
comes loss yeah the revelation feels
like progress but it's actually not
doing anything i mean i've been sober a
long time and you know the adage in
twelfth step is self enough self
knowledge will avail you nothing
right and when people say to me like
well why do you think you were an
alcoholic like what happened when you
it's and i've learned like it's
interesting to explore that but i could
spend
all of my time trying to deconstruct
that
and it actually doesn't help you know it
doesn't it doesn't inform how i'm going
to make decisions going forward
i have this toolbox now and i apply
these tools to how i make decisions and
how i run things by other people
that have allowed me to maintain my
sobriety and
and you know become a more productive
member of society
so for me it's about like the actionable
tools
and i think it is like it's so difficult
for people to change and in my
experience in my own personal experience
like
i didn't change until i was in you know
the the pain of
the pain of continuing on the path that
i was on
exceeded the fear of you know the
unknown should i change
right so you know what is that like like
how do you get people
short of having to have some you know
cataclysm in their life to
make those adjustments and actually you
know put your
information and your insight into
forward motion
there was something that my therapist
said to me that i write about in the
book where he said
you know where i was like just feeling
trapped by all of these sort of external
circumstances and i wasn't willing to
make changes i wasn't willing to look at
what i could do differently
and he said you remind me of this
cartoon and it's of this prisoner
shaking the bars desperately trying to
get out but on the right and the left
the bars are open
and it was like you know at first i
thought that's really cheesy but
but then i thought wait a minute he's
right because so many of us would rather
be the prisoner shaking the bar saying
i can't do anything about this we don't
want to look that it's open on the right
or the left because then if we walk
out and we go into the sunlight and
there are no bars and we're free
with freedom comes responsibility and
now we have to take responsibility for
our lives we can't say oh the problem is
you know that i'm trapped here right now
now it's like
anything that happens is i'm responsible
for that
and so change is hard for that reason
you know it's it's easier to feel
trapped in the
whatever childhood drama you know that
you're you're reenacting
to actually do something different where
you might have to be responsible for
your choices